oh
now disaster has hit my kitchen
welcome to the 2020 tipsy tasty holiday
showdown
today we have a couple of our tasty
producers katie
and jasmine who will be creating holiday
themed dishes with random and limited
ingredients there's going to be cooking
there's going to be alcohol bottoms up
and there's going to be
sabotages what what what in front of you
is the holiday basket with the five
ingredients you must use
in your recipe gingerbread men eggnog
hot cocoa
pound cake and beets beets
i think i've had beets like twice in my
life you can use any additional
ingredients that you want
but it comes at a cost to use a new
ingredient you'll have to take a shot of
bailey's but if that's not enough to
scare you there's going to be a
mid-competition sabotage but we'll get
to that later
a few more side rules since we're
getting tipsy today knives flames and
ovens
are off limits to keep us safe
[Music]
so here's my plan i'll use the
gingerbread men and cocoa powder for the
crust
the eggnog and cake to make the filling
and beet juice to make a festive design
on top it's a no-bake cheesecake
so it could fall apart the only thing
i'm really nervous about is the eggnog
i haven't had eggnog before and so i
haven't used it in cooking before
so here's my plan i'll start by cutting
four inch rounds into my sheet cake
i'll pipe on eggnog and chocolate
buttercream in between each layer
and sprinkle on crumbled gingerbread for
extra texture
and for the top layer i'll spread beet
infused buttercream
top it with a bunch of raspberries and
finish with powdered sugar to look like
a snowy day three two one
go jasmine what are you gonna do to get
started oh
no i have to cut my pound cake but we
don't have knives
what are you gonna do no knife but i
have a plan i'm going to use a bench
scraper
to get as perfect layers as possible i
think it'll work
i'm just going to be putting some of my
cake in a bowl and
i'm going to infuse eggnog with cake oh
that's smart
we'll see how smart it is this is hard
i'm already making a mess
oh my goodness look at how beautifully
precise did it work
we'll work with this there's an easy fix
because i'm gonna have to take a shot
soon for buttercream oh
so you'll just forget about it exactly
have you heard of cereal milk i'm
basically making cake milk
it's just eggnog cake milk does that
sound good
that sounded good now i'm gonna be
taking my eggnog i'm gonna measure out
about a cup and a half that's a lot of
eggnog i'm not gonna use this all
it doesn't look that appetizing but i
feel like it's gonna taste good i'm
using my four inch cookie cutter and i'm
getting
my rounds for the cake since it's gonna
be three tiers i used to eat this
pound cake all the time when i was
younger i didn't have pound cake very
much growing up
there was always one in the freezer at
least one
wait you guys just always had a backup
pound cake so good
my family was like all about the ice
cream you know so i'm gonna let this
cake sit in this eggnog it looks really
unappetizing right now kind of looks
like barf jasmine
this does not look good so katie's looks
like barf and i'm gonna win
how dare you so for my crust i'm gonna
need to take my first shot
i need butter to make this crust i'm
going to need to take my first shot
chop shot shot shot so i just do this
actually i'll need mine very soon should
i take the first one with you yeah let's
do it
all right what are you taking yours for
i'm gonna need buttercream in just a
second
so well shop for some butter and some
buttercream
i've never shopped bailey's i've only
sipped this stuff cheers
cheers it's like chocolate milk i mean
i'll never say no to a drink
but it's a little early to be taking
shots i could never
ever shoot a shot did you get it all the
way yeah i did
it's taken me like four sets come on
katie bottom's up
i got it sounds like a winner that is
delicious though
i just took my first shot and i'm
feeling okay right now
i'm gonna go melt my butter i can't stop
eating the pound cake it's like really
delicious
while my butter is melting i'm gonna
start crushing up some
gingerbread katie guess what what
my entire basket was stolen off my front
porch
all of it all of it and i don't have
gingerbread men i have
ninja bread mess wait that's so much
better than my gingerbread
so for the gingerbread men i would
normally put them in a food processor to
make like a crust but we're not allowed
near those things
because we've had a shot of bailey's so
i'm gonna put it in a plastic bag
and use a rolling pin to crush it i'm
going to start infusing the
buttercream so i'm going to start with
hot cocoa packet to make a cocoa
buttercream i don't think this is
professional i'm using the handle
to crush it whatever gets the job done
you know
are you feeling that shot at all i'm
like a little zen's out
i feel a little fun it's not distracting
me from the challenge at hand this might
be the most chill competition i've ever
done
i'm having a really good time i've added
the hot cocoa to the buttercream but i'm
afraid it won't dissolve so i'm gonna
pop it into the microwave for a little
bit
come on how's it going over there just
getting out all my frustration with 20
20 right now
it's definitely more brown than before
which i'm very happy about let's put
that to the side and mix
our next butter creams this one will be
the beet infused one
i hope i have enough i you know i've
never made this recipe before so i don't
know
if this is gonna work now i'm gonna add
the hot cocoa
powder i'll mix these guys together this
is just gonna add some sweetness
and some chocolatiness now i'm adding in
my beet juice to color this
buttercream so red that's insane
look at this katie whoa it looks like
halloween
i love halloween it doesn't look like
christmas yet
not yet so to my cookies and my cocoa
powder i'm gonna add some of that melted
butter that i had to take a shot for
um all right i'm gonna try this ginger
butter chocolate crust and see how it
tastes
oh yummy you need it to be wet sand
because this is a no bake it really
needs to stick together when you put it
in the fridge
i'm feeling pretty good about this so
far i finally got my pound cake
thawed and now we're just gonna get a
four inch round from here
you're stressed you stressed i'm not
stressed no stress here
hands up ladies it's time for a mid
competition challenge what
no i'm in the middle of straining eggnog
what are we doing
i sent you both some icing and a
blindfold put on that blindfold
and you'll have just 60 seconds to
decorate a gingerbread man she said
blindfolded
yeah this is hard then we'll post on
instagram and let you guys pick your
favorite the winner
gets used with free extra ingredients
but the loser
has to take another shot i don't want to
take an extra shot no bring it on
looks like this mid competition game is
in my favor i'm very good at cookie
decorating
i'm so nervous all right we got this all
right let's do it
i don't even know what color is what oh
shoot i didn't look
oh no three two one
decorate this is impossible is it even
coming out oh yeah it is oh it's on my
finger
how do you do this we only have one
minute you know what i'm just gonna go
for like a different
type of guy i don't know what i'm doing
i can't see any of the colors i can't
see the cookie so i am just gonna go
with an abstract design oh shoot
i forgot i have a ninja bread man this
is not normal shape
i don't know what color i'm doing now oh
this is probably bad
i'm probably piping all over the counter
[Laughter]
i'm sure mine looks amazing actually i
can't tell where he is okay
just one button i have to like orient
where his little foot is
time's up back away from the table and
icing down
i don't even want to look
it looks like was bleeding out its ears
look at it bleeding
i'm very good at cookie decorating
looks like his heart is in his knee now
that we have pictures of both of your
cookies let's post it on instagram and
see who gets more votes
the results are in and to everyone's
surprise the person who gets an extra
ingredient
is katie yay
this like bodes very well for me
bogus katie just went all
pretty pretty stripes he's a little
jackson pollocky
this masterpiece that should honestly
just be in a museum
beauty is in the eye of the beholder
joke's on you katie i threw the
competition so i could have another shot
yeah cheers cheers
oh god did you do that all in one yes i
did
i'm so impressed by you all right so
what are you gonna do now i think we
should take a dance break
that's what i think dance break dance
break i'm too sober for this dance right
i'm feeling it back to the dish what do
you have to do now i need to
put my buttercream into piping bags and
i'll begin
piping the first and second layer what
about you katie
i'm gonna take my eggnog cake thing
and strain it through a sieve or
strainer
it's gonna be a slow process so how is
the piping going
i have my new reusable piping bag oh
what happened did the stirring get away
from you the buttercream moves so fast
and i'm not moving very fast right now
all my big cake chunks are out of my
eggnog milk i'm going to set this to the
side
and i'm going to whip up some oh i need
to take a shot
oh for what i need to take a shot for my
cream cheese
i can already tell the next few hours
are going to be tough especially if i
have to take
more shots well here is my much deserved
cream cheese since i took that shot
i'm going to mix up this cream cheese
until it's super light and fluffy i'm
gonna put the buttercream in my piping
bag
great i'm gonna start adding in my
eggnog i think i'm just gonna do a half
a cup
hopefully that'll be enough flavor
oh my god what i'm supposed to infuse
this buttercream with eggnog
this is why you should not drink and
cook i've reset my buttercream and now i
can add some eggnog but i'm not gonna
add too much
because i don't want it to get really
runny like the beet one my cheesecake is
like not sweet it's just
cheese in it i'm going to use sugar as
my extra ingredient smart
then i don't have to take a shot i'm
pouring some eggnog into the squeeze
bottle
bakeries when they want to moisten cakes
they'll sometimes do this with like
simple syrup or butter
and i'm going to go with eggnog so i
just tasted some of my eggnog filling
adding some powdered sugar and this will
be my extra bonus ingredient i got from
the cookie challenge
back to putting the buttercream into the
piping bag but this time
infused with eggnog let's try this
much better much closer to cheesecake
for my next step i'm gonna finally begin
putting these layers of cake together
and i'm gonna start with my cocoa cream
and i'll alternate it with my eggnog
cream so
it'll look like checkers when you cut
into it next i'm gonna add
heavy whipping cream to a bowl
and this is what makes it a no-bake
cheesecake the whipping cream is gonna
help hold its shape once i whip it up
so whoa oh
i need to take a shot good heavy
whipping cream
is a new ingredient when are you taking
your next shots
i need raspberries next okay take a shot
for your raspberries with me
fine i think this is the last one i need
to take too
thank the lord cheers all right here we
go
who is party
i just took another shot and i'm feeling
like things will go downhill pretty
quickly
so ugly oh what is
happening over there what are you doing
is that your buttercream melting
why don't you put your buttercream in
the fridge or the freezer just to get
chilly a little bit
i think we should just stop and we
should just hang out
justin wants to hang out right now and
just like play but like we have a
competition to do
this is pretty fun i could do this more
often
all right my whipped cream is super
whipped and now i'm going to
fold in the eggnog mixture we want to
fold it in so that it doesn't deflate
our whipped cream
you're kind of making basically a
cheesecake mousse
i need like a rotating cake
stand thingy i'm trying to even out the
cake layers because one of them is
higher than the other
you know what that'll just have to do
i'll even it out with a
buttercream i think i got all my layers
on how's it looking
really ugly great great for you horrible
for me
i would just never win a competition
that's fine you will
win a competition will i win today katie
i don't know if i'm gonna win i don't
even know if this tastes good remember
when i was gonna make a cheesecake with
no sugar
yeah i missed those times no that was 10
minutes ago
and then i'm going to take some of the
juice from my beets and
dye this red but i don't want to put too
much in
i'm going to town on this baby i feel
like it's just going into like
purple land here okay let me let me
taste this
earthy it tastes like dirt i'm gonna go
get my crust
and then i'm going to start putting this
together look it's actually not that bad
that's actually pretty oh i missed a
whole side so i have my crust and i'm
going to place my filling on top
i'm going to put this back in the fridge
so we can set a little bit more i've
prepared my raspberries that i will put
on the top of the cake
and then i'll need to take a shot for
powdered sugar cheers katie
cheers thanks for the thumbs up
i said in the beginning that i'm a
lightweight but after seeing jasmine i
think i might be like
heavyweight so right now i'm just taking
an offset spatula and trying to smooth
out
as best i can you must think wow this is
such an easy competition
but you know what at the end i'm gonna
be like
whoa i don't even know what i'm doing
anymore i'm just gonna like
plop some dots of it i'm gonna take a
wooden stake and just swirl it through
this
is kind of working this looks like a
valentine's day cake
pretty great whatever you're doing keep
on doing it i can't tell if that's
because you want me to be bad
no definitely not that one but it's
finally great to feel like i'm i'm ahead
you know what it kind of looks like
retro like it looks like a christmas
thing that my grandma would like
i'm gonna go put this in the fridge the
chill i don't want to take another shot
but i
really want to make a garnish on top of
this cheesecake
so bottoms up
i'm gonna go melt some chocolate so i've
taken my shot feeling great
i've put the chocolate in a piping bag
and i've melted it and i'm going to pipe
out some
chocolate tree garnishes i have finally
gotten to a place where i like my cake
but i think i want to put a little bit
more buttercream on it so i'm going to
pop this in the fridge and take it back
out in five minutes
i made my trees huge oh my god those are
adorable
but i'm afraid they're not gonna stay
together so we'll see
i finally got the cake to a good place
and i forgot to sprinkle
in my crumbled gingerbread in between
the layers so i'm just gonna do it
around the base
of the cake i'm gonna take my chocolate
trees that have pretty much set and i'm
gonna put them into my
cheesecake those are cute i'm now adding
my raspberries on the top
of my cake what my freaking
beet buttercream i'm too tipsy and i
forgot
every step like i have been doing for
the past
many steps i don't even know where my
buttercream is i have a lot of garland
here and i have such an urge to wear it
like a boa
you totally should i support that what
am i doing
okay katie welcome to my show where i
beat my friend
oh wow i do think yours is gonna taste
very good
i'm gonna make it snow oh my favorite
part i think that looks really pretty
i think we're about ready to pack these
up and have kelly come and pick these up
from us
i hope it doesn't taste too much of
beets
looking at jasmine's i love the
raspberries on top with the powdered
sugar it looks like snow
and looking at katie's i really like
these chocolate trees they are so cute
but the most important thing is taste so
let's give these a try
okay guys i've tried both dishes jasmine
i really love your creative use of the
buttercream but i kind of felt like the
gingerbread was an afterthought
katie i love that you incorporated cocoa
powder into the crust
but i do think your feeling could have
been a tad bit sweeter but the winner i
chose today
really impressed me with her
presentation and creativity
the winner is jasmine
[Music]
i won i think jasmine did a really good
job i'm not surprised she won
hers looked like it was out of a bake
shop good job katie
for helping me win i mean at the end of
all this
i had a really good time i'm still tipsy
so i'm feeling the festive holiday
spirit and i think we should do this
again
thanks so much for tuning in to
tipsytasty's holiday showdown
happy holidays and let us know in the
comments below if we should do this
again
have a merry christmas
or a happy holidays oh my god you have a
garland with lights
yes i'm a crafty gal okay bye guys bye
oh yes
[Music]
foreign